i'm kind of scared of coffee because you
know like when you're a kid and everyone
is like
don't drink coffee it'll stunt your
growth and i was a short kid already so
i was like
i'm not even gonna try coffee in the
first place i need to hit that
six foot marker at least
[Music]
yo what's up gq it's your boy 24k golden
and here are my essentials
[Music]
all right so my first essential item is
this diptych candle right here
when you're on the road or when you're
in the house it's just important to
create a vibe an environment that you
feel comfortable
living in working in having fun in
there's no better way to create a unique
sensory experience
than by changing the changing up the
smell you know we got this nice kendall
from diptique
really really big lasts a long time it's
just
elegant and refined like it's not gonna
smell like
a seventh grade boys locker room but
it's also
not gonna be so light that you don't
get any change in sense at all it's
something like sweet but
a little spicy so like a vanilla spice
or something like that we try and
keep it smelling nice when we can my
next essential
is a neck pillow
these are perfect for when you're on the
road you know this one right here is
more like a memory foam kind of vibe
this neck pillow right here
changed my life it was the cheapest one
in the airport gift shop
i just tried it out and i was like yo it
kind of hit different
it took me from not being able to sleep
on planes at all to like i can literally
fall asleep anywhere at this point
honestly if i forgot my neck pillow then
i have to buy another one at the airport
and that's how i ended up with five not
because
i wanted to own five of them but because
i forgot it so many times at the crib
just
leaving for an early morning or late
night flight that i'm like all right i
have to get something or else
i'll be up for five hours in this most
uncomfortable position possible
and this one is obviously baked in case
you know i just gotta
flex a little bit walking through the
airport and i'm feeling like flexing
extra hard that day
my next essential is yerba mate okay
this is the lifeblood of my entire
career at this point i do a lot of [ __ ]
every day
and that takes energy okay and when
you're waking up early and going to bed
late
one thing you don't have a lot of is
energy so this is like all natural
it's from south america and it's just a
better way to get
energy and caffeine without getting a
crazy amount of sugar
or like some artificial weird stuff in
there it hits me pretty fast
i'm a lightweight so i don't know it
might be different for other people
my next essential is socks
[Music]
i used to be the type of kid when i grew
up i would just wear a straight nike
crew sock
and have like the dirty ass bottoms
because i was running around everywhere
with no shoes on
but you know i'm a little older now i'm
a little more refined
and i understand that that your socks
matter just as much as the rest of the
outfit but
these ain't no regular socks these are
cool socks right so
these first ones i got right here these
are the custom
24k golden exclusive paper boy socks
okay
money bag boys we in this thing for me
the most important thing when i'm buying
my socks is
design and comfort if it looks good but
it doesn't feel good
i can't really wear it all day but if it
feels good and it doesn't look good
it's going to mess up my fits so you
know everything's got to be on point
my next essential item is skincare
first we got this hyaluronic hyaluronic
hyaluronic i don't even know how to
pronounce this serum
the secret weapon and then we got boom
the face cream
for men i don't know what the difference
between the one for men and the one for
woman is
but it says for men so i had to let
y'all know and then
the enzyme cleanser and you know
my skins never look better i got into
skincare cause
my mom and my sister have like really
nice skin and you know i'm in middle
school i'm getting my first pimples i'm
like
yo how do i get rid of this and my mom's
like all right don't worry
i'm gonna put you on so i've always
known that you gotta take care of your
your face and friend of mine she knew
barbara and she was like
yo you gotta try these out and i'm like
yeah you know i'll try it out let me see
what it's like
and my skin has never been so clear
these are just like super gentle
everything smells good like not too
scented but
just like scented enough to feel fresh
and relaxed
it's like this is a commercial me
familia
this is a picture of my family i think
this was probably
like almost a year ago wow so this is my
dad
this is my mom this is my sister and uh
this is my twin brother i couldn't make
it that day
no i'm just playing that's me i grew up
in san francisco california
as the cardigan implies my family we've
always been really close
my parents are super supportive of
whatever it is you want to do just
be great at it and if it's making you
happy it's making them happy
my sister she's like a volleyball
aficionado
and like a genius in school i think she
got like a 4.3 or something
right now gpa so props to her
i talk to my family like by text or
facetime or call
every week really like multiple times a
week my mom is always
hitting me sometimes you know even when
i don't want her to but she stays
checking in
my airpods if you didn't know
i make music so it's kind of important
for me to be able to listen to music on
a regular basis
what i like about those ones in
particular is when i'm traveling like on
the plane or
something like that i can put the noise
cancellation mode in and
all the crying babies all the turbulence
all the you know announcements is all
drowned out and i could just listen to
my music
fall asleep and vibe out but every time
i
wake up off off an airplane nap i have
at least one airpod missing so i got to
be the guy like
at the end of the fight digging under my
seat looking for that left
airpod pro like help like where the
flight attendants you guys help me
that's me every time the only thing i
wish that they did that they don't do is
connect to the actual airplane
uh tv so i could like watch movies and
then listen to it on my airpod
and i have to use those janky ass five
dollar headphones off of the delta
flights because
this is not it calvin klein boxer briefs
a lot of people wear boxers a lot of
people wear briefs
me i can't do anything but the boxer
brief it's just
the right combination of comfort
length and aesthetic to be honest briefs
they're way too short and it's like
you look like you're still in fifth
grade or something like that like
if you're a grown man wearing briefs you
need to you need to check yourself bro
boxes on the other hand they're too
stiff they're not really that
comfortable
me i like calvin klein because when you
like reach up and a little bit of your
boxers
show it's like a little flex to the
ladies let them know yo
these these family jewels are are are
surrounded by delicate material
and my final item is a book called
be here now ram dash and this is
actually an original one
in this career of being an artist it's
easy to get caught up in
you know the day-to-day stuff there's
the shows and
the fame and all that but i find that
i'm
most happy when i'm in the present
moment taken in my surroundings
the people i'm with the things i enjoy
this book is one of those things that
kind of just keeps you in the present
i just find something new in there every
time pick a random page and
see what it's got to say to you all
right
that's it gq uh thanks for checking out
my essentials i hope you have a
wonderful day
and remember stay golden